U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
says Washington will not let Iran
develop nuclear weapons speaking at the
American Israel public affairs committee
blinken also urged the normalization of
relations between Saudi Arabia and
Israel he made those comments just hours
before leaving for talks in Riyadh Saudi
Arabia
the United States has a real National
Security interest in promoting
normalization between Israel and Saudi
Arabia
We Believe
that we can and indeed we must play an
integral role in advancing it now
we have no illusions that this can be
done quickly or easily
but
we remain committed to working toward
that outcome including on the trip I'm
about to take this week to Jetta and
Riyadh for engagements with our Saudi
and Gulf counterparts
a White House correspondent Kimberly
Halka joins us live Kimberly good to
talk to you the the U.S calling for
Saudi Israel normalization because we're
going to start there that's not new
however the context in which blinken is
saying that is new the Middle East is
changing very rapidly right now and
blinken is headed there tomorrow so how
should we interpret this from the U.S
Secretary of State then
uh we should interpret that it's really
a top priority for the United States and
you heard it there really in the first
words from Anthony blinken as he talked
out of his mouth there uh that it's it's
a top priority for U.S security the
United States sees this is absolutely
integral to its National Security here
in the United States and so as a result
the USC's itself is being absolutely
critical in advancing the integration of
Israel in the region and so that is what
he is going to be doing is he makes his
way to the region he feels that at this
point or this the Biden Administration
does that Saudi Arabia up to this point
has kind of held back it has certainly
opened up to commercial flights between
Riyadh as well as Israel but there
certainly is more that can be done and
so that is what these discussions are
going to be about trying to advance that
relationship in order that there can be
a sort of a stable prosperous but also
integrated relationship in the broader
Middle East now the biggest obstacle you
also heard there the United States
believes is Iran and its aspirations for
acquiring a nuclear weapon and the U.S
is underscored once again that that is a
no-go to the United States the body
Administration once again reiterating
that all options will be on the table to
if Iran chooses to ignore diplomacy to
make sure that it does not acquire a
nuclear weapon tell us a little bit more
about Lincoln's visit to the gulf he's
going to be in Saudi Arabia which at the
moment is the Big Driver of change in
the Middle East what can you tell us
about that
well what I can tell you is that this is
really something that has been
incremental so the Abraham Accords which
some people may be familiar with others
may not it's something that is being
built upon it started in the previous
Trump Administration uh really was an
economic idea to expand prosperity and
to integrate Israel with the broader
Arab Middle East and this is something
that is being expanded upon under the
Biden Administration and so there's a
parallel effort that's also taking place
in order to accomplish this in the U.S
Congress so this is the Biden
Administration acting upon this sort of
phase two if you will but to that end
what we also know is that it's not going
to be quick it's going to take a lot of
Engagement a lot of conversation that's
what's happening with the secretary of
state right now but there's another
point we should quickly mention in all
of this is that the uh Senate Secretary
of State Anthony blinken says don't
mistake this for the other big task at
hand and that is making sure that
there's peace in the Middle East when it
comes to between the Israelis and the
Palestinians that is also a top priority
for the Biden Administration Kimberly
halket reporting from the White House
thank you very much Kimberly